she-hulk attorney at law has an amazing
lead the return of professor hulk and
some surprising mcu connections so what
do you need to know before the big
premiere keep watching to find out
at the d23 presentation in 2019 ms
marvel moon knight and she-hulk were all
announced as upcoming series for disney
plus and marvel studios almost three
years later to the day she-hulk attorney
at law is scheduled to drop on the
streamer on august 17 2022 the series
will follow the same format as one
division running for a total of nine
shorter episodes as opposed to the mcu's
other shows with six one hour-ish
episodes new episodes will drop at 3am
eastern on disney plus every wednesday
if she hulk attorney at law follows the
once per week format the series will
conclude with its finale on october 12th
this puts the new show smack dab in the
middle of the release dates for thor
love and thunder and black panther
wakanda forever
joining the mcu and she-hulk attorney at
law is orphan black star tatiana maslany
as jennifer walters aka she-hulk in
december 2020 marvel studios revealed
the casting news on social media after
maslany denied her involvement just two
months prior the new series marks the
first live-action project from mazlany
sends her stint on hbo's perry mason in
2020. mazlani spoke a little about her
upcoming role in she-hulk while chatting
with empire magazine the canadian
actress said part of her inspiration for
playing jennifer came from the late
scottish musician sophie she told empire
what i love about sophie's music is this
combo of organic and electrical
industrial type sounds that felt
connected to she-hulk when it comes to
her character the actress called her
story the antithesis of most superhero
narratives suggesting we're about to get
a whole new take on mcu heroes
the second original avenger getting some
time in an mcu disney plus series is
mark ruffalo returning to the role of
bruce banner after his appearance in the
post-credits of chongqi and the legends
of the ten rings ruffalo's last major
mcu role was in avengers end game and it
looks like she-hulk attorney-at-law
might be his final performance with the
studio based on comments he made to
access hollywood at the atom project
premiere it's been speculated that
ruffalo will retire from the mcu he had
high praise for mazlany freaking
legendary as a she-hulk
i'm passing the banner onto her
based on what we see in the trailer for
she-hulk he'll serve as something of a
hulk coach to jennifer walters while she
acclimates to her newfound powers
after almost a year of rumors the good
place actress jamila jamil confirmed she
was joining the mcu in she-hulk attorney
at law in her debut tick-tock post
jameel will play titania aka mary
mcferrin a long-time rival of she-hulk
the comic book version of mary gains her
powers from doctor doom after she's
swept away into battle world she wields
superhuman strength and is an expert in
hand-to-hand combat she's quite the
match for she-hulk but normally finds
herself the loser in their many battles
since the good place concluded in 2020
jameel has been more selective about the
projects she takes on jameel told
hollywoodlife i always want what i do to
try and align or embolden my social
justice work i feel like that is
something that we are achieving with
this show we're saying something
important we're doing something
important we're pushing the boundaries
when a new mcu project is on the horizon
a frenzy begins online as fans try to
figure out if there will be any cameos
she hulk attorney at law is no different
only this time around two cameos have
already been confirmed by marvel studios
and disney after appearing in 2021's
chongqi and to the legend of the ten
rings for a brief fight scene
abomination will return for she-hulk
this time we'll get to see him in his
human form and emil blonsky played by
tim roth even makes an appearance in the
trailer he's locked in a special cell so
we know he's still not to be trusted 14
years after his mcu introduction
how do you feel
this stuff i'm ready for round three
also joining she hulk attorney at law is
wang played by benedict wong fresh off
his recent appearance in doctor strange
in the multiverse of madness we haven't
seen wong yet in a trailer for the show
but since he was the sorcerer fighting
abomination in chongqi and the legend of
the ten rings it makes sense that he
would show up there are plenty of other
rumors suggesting characters from all
across the mcu will cameo from liv
tyler's return as betty ross to kristen
ritter reprising her role as jessica
jones but these should be taken with a
grain of salt
the first official trailer for she-hulk
attorney at lost shocked the mcu fandom
by giving them a brief glimpse of
frogman a popular twitter spoiler
account had previously leaked the
character's inclusion in the series but
it wasn't taken too seriously at the
time no actor has been connected to
frogman but with josh segarra and
griffin matthews attached to unknown
characters it's reasonably safe to
assume one of them is playing the
obscure character not to be confused
with his dad the villainous leapfrog
frogman first appeared in 1982's marvel
team-up number 121 when leapfrog real
name vincent patilio gets arrested and
put away his son eugene decides to use
the mantle as a force for good under the
modified identity of frogman there is no
substantial direct connection between
jennifer walters and eugene in the
comics however leapfrog's criminal
endeavors frequently pit him against
daredevil and matt murdock just so
happens to be a lawyer who recently made
his post-netflix mcu debut in spider-man
no way home so that connection could
explain his appearance
according to the official synopsis from
disney plus she-hulk attorney at law
will focus on jennifer walters an
attorney working at a firm that deals
with superhuman clients jennifer will
also navigate a complicated love life
which is depicted in the first trailer
for the series as she searches for dates
jennifer will be in her hulk form as it
looks like the world has already
accepted her new look as previously
mentioned mark ruffalo's hulk will teach
jennifer how to handle her new six foot
seven inch form and superhuman strength
everything looks fresh for jennifer and
she-hulk as she is taking on a new job
new physique and new romantic interests
all at the same time not to mention her
first opponent in titania there's a
brief moment in the trailer where the
two women battle it out in a courtroom
but the root of their issues in this
particular series is still in the air
much as the hawkeye mantle was passed on
to kate bishop and hawkeye we expect the
same sort of thing to happen in she-hulk
with maslany being the mcu's primary
green giant moving forward yes yes yes
no no
we all know by now how bruce banner gets
his powers but the origin of she-hulk's
powers is a little more obscure simply
because the character has spent
comparatively little time in mainstream
media unless you are a marvel comics
reader you might be totally unaware of
how jennifer bulks up based on what we
see in the trailer we expect to see
jennifer get her powers early in the
series it would be a surprise to find
out she already has them by the time the
show begins although that's not
impossible here's how it goes down
jennifer is shot by a man named nicholas
trask who is seeking revenge against her
father her wounds are grave and she
needs a blood transfusion so her cousin
bruce steps up to help her out when
there are no other options with gamma
radiation coursing through his veins
there was no way to avoid jennifer
getting the irradiated blood into her
system but it's not just bruce's blood
that turns her it's her anger and fear
that really does the trick those are
like the baseline of any woman just
existing and just like that she becomes
superhuman jennifer is not quite as
powerful as bruce in her hulk form and
her stature is slightly smaller which
makes her look more human-like and less
monster-like
as with the three most recent marvel
studios disney plus series she-hulk
attorney at la will have more than one
director she-hulk will be split between
cat coiro and a new valia koiro has
directed episodes of popular projects
like dead to me and it's always sunny in
philadelphia while valia is known for
her work on ap bio and the sex and the
city revival series and just like that
koiro pushed hard to get the job telling
collider i'm a huge fan of the mcu and i
was actually a giant fan of the she-hulk
comics so when i heard they were making
it i went full court press and really
sold myself as the person to bring this
story to life it was a huge and involved
process in an instagram post from
december 2020 valia revealed koiro is
taking the lead on she-hulk attorney at
law writing friggin stoked to go on this
ride together koiro is our visionary
leader i'm just doing a few epis but
it'll be a fun one
the hollywood reporter revealed that
jessica gao was hired as head writer for
she-hulk attorney at law back in
november 2019 gow is an emmy-winning
writer who nabbed the gold statue for
her work on the rick and morty episode
pickle rick she also has writing credits
on robot chicken big time rush and
silicon valley just to name a few gao
was absolutely flabbergasted to get the
job on she-hulk and shared her
excitement in an instagram post after
the big news was announced she wrote
dream come true i am deceased don't
worry i will resurrect to do the job
subsequent social media posts of gows
regarding the new disney plus series
have only mirrored her initial
excitement she shared casting news to
her feed and when the first trailer was
released gao also told the world on
instagram that she couldn't wait for
everyone to see mazlani in the role
we know for certain that she hulk
attorney at la connects to shanghi and
the legend of the ten rings in a minor
way with a blink and you'll miss it
confirmation in the trailer when we see
wang leaving the fight club in the phase
4 film he opens a portal and on the
other side is a room with a large cell
in the middle of it the same cell can be
seen in the she-hulk trailer where
jennifer walters talks to an imprisoned
emil blonsky as far as future projects
it's possible we'll see she-hulk connect
to the thunderbolts movie recently
declared as in development some fans
think a meal is being held in the cube a
shield prison that houses various
super-powered criminals occasionally of
the gamma-irradiated variety all we're
saying is if valentina allegra
defontaine needs someone to join a team
already consisting of john walker and
yelena bulova she could probably swing
by the cube and offer emil a deal
without much trouble
fans weren't too happy with the quality
of the cgi in the first she-hulk
attorney at law trailer but that's not
the only controversy surrounding the
series a few sources have come forward
to say there were some problems behind
the scenes former variety and collider
writer jeff snyder revealed in march
2022 on his the hot mic with jeff and
john podcast that he's heard about
issues with she-hulk claiming i've heard
not good things behind the scenes and
i've asked whether it's moon knight or
ms marvel or secret invasion or any of
these projects they are always like
she-hulk is the one that could be a
problem former hollywood reporter editor
matthew baloney mentioned in his
website's newsletter in may 2022 that
the newest disney plus series are being
watched carefully writing the upcoming
she-hulk is supposedly a mess i've heard
even with mark ruffalo in a small role
and ms marvel is another big test for
fans nobody's saying marvel's tv output
is in trouble but it's something to keep
an eye on
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
the marvel cinematic universe are coming
soon subscribe to our youtube channel
and hit the bell so you don't miss a
single one
[Music]